i'm joined the chance of the exchequer
and the secretary of state for health
and social care because today we're
setting out our plan to help our nhs
recover from the pandemic and build back
better by fixing the problems in health
and social care that governments have
avoided for decades
we all know someone whose test scan or
hip replacement was delayed
or who helped protect the nhs amid the
immense pressures of covid by putting
off treatment for a new medical
condition
and now as people come forward again
we need to pay for those missed
operations and treatments
we need to pay good wages for the 50 000
extra nurses we're recruiting and we
need to go beyond the record funding
we've already provided to the nhs that
means going further than the 48
hospitals and 50 million more gp
appointments
so today
following the most successful vaccine
program in the world we're beginning the
biggest catch-up program in the history
of the nhs
increasing hospital capacity by 110
and enabling 9 million more appointments
scans and operations and i have to level
with people waiting lists will get worse
before they get better
but compared with before covid by 2024
2025
our plan will allow the nhs to aim to
treat 30 percent more patients who need
elective care like knee replacements or
cancer screening
a recovery on this scale
cannot be delivered by cheese pairing
budgets elsewhere
and it would be irresponsible to cover a
permanent increase in health and social
care spending with higher day-to-day
borrowing
for more than 70 years
we've lived by the principle that
everyone pays through through our taxes
for the nhs
so it's there for all of us when we need
it
in that spirit from april we will have a
new uk wide 1.25
health and social care levy on earned
income
with the money required by law to go
directly to health and social care
across the whole of our united kingdom
and with dividend rates
increasing by the same amount
this will raise almost 36 billion pounds
over the next three years
not just funding more care but better
care including better screening
equipment to diagnose cancer earlier and
digital technologies allowing doctors to
monitor patients in their homes
the levy will share the cost
as fairly as possible between people and
businesses because we all benefit from a
well-supported nhs and all businesses
benefit from a healthy workforce
and those who earn more will pay more
including those who continue to work
after the stay over the state pension
age
the highest earning 14 percent of the
population will pay around half of the
revenue raised no one
earning less than
9568 pounds will pay a penny
and most small businesses will be
protected with 40
paying nothing extra at all
and this new investment will go
alongside vital reform
because we learned from the pandemic
that we can't fix the nhs
unless we also fix
social care
when kovid struck
there were 30 000 hospital beds in
england
occupied by people who would have been
better cared for elsewhere
and the inevitable consequence was that
patients couldn't get the hip operations
or cancer treatment or whatever other
help they needed
and those people were often in hospital
because they feared the costs of care in
a residential home
if you suffer from cancer or heart
disease
the nhs will cover the costs
of your treatment in full
but if you develop alzheimer's or
parkinson's
then you have to pay for everything
above a very low threshold
today
one in seven of us can expect to face
care costs exceeding a hundred thousand
pounds in our later years
and millions millions more
live in fear that they could be among
the one in seven
suppose you have a house worth two
hundred fifty thousand pounds and you're
in a care home for eight years
then once you've paid your bills
you could be left with just fourteen
thousand pounds after a lifetime of work
and effort and saving
having sacrificed everything else
everything that you would otherwise have
passed on to your children
simply
to avoid the indignity
of suffering
so we're doing something that frankly
should have been done
a long time ago
and share the risk of these catastrophic
care costs
so that everyone is relieved of that
fear of financial ruin
we're setting a limit to what people
will ever have to pay regardless of
assets or income
in england from october 2023
no one starting care will pay more than
eighty six thousand pounds over their
lifetime
no one with assets of less than twenty
thousand pounds will have to pay
anything at all
and anyone with assets of between twenty
thousand pounds and a hundred thousand
pounds will be eligible for means-tested
support
and will also address the fear that many
have
about how their parents or grandparents
will be looked after
will invest in the quality of care and
in carers
themselves with 500 million pounds going
to hundreds of thousands of new training
places
mental health support for carers and
improved recruitment
making sure that caring is a properly
respected profession in its own right
and will integrate health and social
care in england so that all elderly and
disabled people are looked after with
the dignity they deserve
no
conservative government wants to raise
taxes
but nor could we in good conscience meet
the cost of this plan
simply by borrowing the money
and imposing the burden on future
generations so i'll be absolutely frank
with you this new levy will break our
manifesto commitment
but a global pandemic wasn't in our
manifesto either and everyone knows in
their bones
that after everything we've spent to
protect people
through that crisis
we cannot now shirk the challenge of
putting the nhs back on its feet
which requires
fixing the problem of social care and
investing the money needed
so we will do what is right
and reasonable and fair we'll make up
the covid backlogs we'll fund more
nurses
and i hope we will remove the anxiety of
millions of families up and down the
land
by taking forward reforms that have been
delayed for far too long